you know if you've got yourself a nice
Islamic wife she wouldn't cheat on you
should cook for you she'd look after you
she wouldn't have an only fans you know
most of the problems you're facing
currently with women can be solved by
Islam
really
I just told you why wait they actually
don't cheat
she'd have decency she'd cover up she'd
be God-fearing if she her family would
also keep an eye on her so her family
would tell her to obey her husband she
want your children she'd look after you
Islamic women are the best they
understand that the best way to serve
God is to also serve their husbands
where do I get one at well most of your
problems could be solved where do I get
an Islamic you must become a Muslim
yourself first my friend
and and being a Muslim is not easy
there's a lot to learn it's a long
journey even I'm not a scholar I'm
learning there's a lot to learn about
how it works and the true word of God
and the Quran and learning Arabic Etc is
not easy but if you come to Dubai you
can begin the journey and you can talk
to the same people I've talked to and
then you get yourself an Islamic wife
and before you know